bonjour et merci d'être avec nous alors
plus d'un million de cas de corona virus
sur le continent africain
est ce que ce chiffre vous inquiète il
est il est inquiétant c'est normal c'est
parce que le nombre augmente parce que
quand on voit les statistiques qui sont
donnés actuellement on al impression qu
aucun pays n'a qu'à son pic mais là où
c'est un peu moins inquiétant c'est que
au regard des dessertes e se rend compte
que la l'impression que la pathologie en
afrique elle pas aussi mortel que ça
dans la plupart des pays quand on est à
côté par exemple l'afrique du sud qui a
le plus de monde en terme de légalité
elle semble être moins létale en afrique
qu'ailleurs parce qu'effectivement on a
plus d'un million de personnes affectées
mais 22000 à peu près 22 mille personnes
décédées selon les derniers chiffres de
l' oms met toutefois on voit que la
propagation du virus poursuit ici
oui la propagation se confirme mais en
fait encore une fois il faudrait qu'on
fasse un peu plus attention aux chiffres
parce que en afrique
je crois que c'est un des continents où
ils se sont mis à tester le plus vous
voyez et tous les hôpitaux test de tous
les passagers qui arrivent tests sont
testés ce qui n'est même pas forcément
le cas un peu un peu ailleurs
donc ça veut dire que plus comme disait
un des remises plus en test plus tôt
alors quand l'afrique pendant longtemps
il ya des pays avec un seul laboratoire
qui pourrait être question au moment du
début est aujourd'hui en appelait à
plein le laboratoire de test donc c'est
normal qu'on ait de plus en plus de cas
et ça s'est juste dit dû au fait que
l'on en a fait un geste de plus en plus
alors vous parlez des tests et selon le
centre de contrôle et de prévention des
maladies et plus de 80% de ces tests
qu'ovide réalisées sur le continent ont
été effectués dans seulement dix pays
est ce que le problème ne se trouverait
pas là dans cette pénurie de test puis
il ya beaucoup de pays dans lesquels
visiblement on teste pas oui mais ça
peut les aider l'armée quand on regarde
aussi les pays où on a le plus testé
c'est le pays où on a effectivement le
plus de cas
mais quand on place d'autres pays qui
sont assez pauvres en dehors de la
capitale et de la grande ville
demandez à un paysan de faire 150 km
pour aller se tester alors qu'il va bien
et il va pas le faire donc ça fait qu'
il ya des raisons objectives logistique
qui font qu'il ya certains pays peuvent
être testé massivement une peu testé que
dans l'est dans les grandes villes
ça fait vraiment un des aspects donc
ceux qui ont testé le plus à ceux qui
avaient le plus de moyens donc qu'ils
ont pu joindre une population plus
élargie et ils ont pu faire qui réalisé
beaucoup de tests et quand je parlais
aussi de faire attention un peu aussi
vous voyez quelqu'un qui décède il
décède d'une embolie pulmonaire ou de
nersac us et qu'on réalise qu'il est
positif
oco bible est ce que c'est le convive
qui l'a tué ou fait cinq ans que la tuer
mais il avait le pauvre qui me fait
derrière
donc ça c'est à ce niveau là au niveau
de l'afrique en particulier et dans
d'autres pays même certains pays très
développé les chiffres sont à prendre
vraiment avec quelqu un certain soin
est-ce que les hôpitaux peuvent faire
face à cette pandémie on sait que
l'algérie le ghana l'egypte le nigeria
et l'afrique du sud
les grandes nations du continent font
partie des plus touchés du continent oui
ce sont les grandes nations et c'est un
peu ce qu'ils sont un peu plus nantis
que les autres quand vous prenez la
route du sud le niveau de la médecine
elle est très élevée quand on a l'argent
c'est pas toujours élevé pour tout le
monde c'est à dire les gens qui n'ont
pas suffisamment de moyens ne peuvent
pas se soigner correctement ils sont
aussi comme tout le reste de l'afrique
ou connaît l'algérie le maroc ce sont
des endroits où il ya quand même un
minimum de niveau d'équipement et c'est
peut-être pour ça que c'est dans ces
pays aussi conteste contexte beaucoup
plus mais qu incarne depuis vingt chars
je pense qu'ils sont en mesure de
prendre à charge parce que le plus de
cas ne veut pas dire le plus de cas
hospitalisés
et quand on réalise le nombre de cas
hospitalisés par rapport au nombre de
cas positive
ce n'est pas très important encore une
fois la population africaine et
lectrices je ne m'a plus de quand on
prend la fuite
en général surtout au succès à rennes on
a plus de 60 % de gens qui ont à peine
30 ans concrètement et ceux de 65 ans
ceux qui ont plus de 65 ans ne
représentent que 2% de la population
alors que leurs 60 plus de 60% de la
population des pays et des pays
européens par exemple
donc il ya une forte prévalence une
forte population qui est positive mais
qui ne nécessitera pas une
hospitalisation
donc je pense que les hôpitaux peuvent
faire face la vie fut le seul
inconvénient c'est tout ce qui concerne
le matériel en particulier tous les
consommables les gangs pour le matériel
de protection
rapidement au niveau justement des
équipements médicaux est ce que la
plupart des pays sont assez équipés pour
faire face à l'arrivée de nouveaux
patients je parle par exemple des lits
de réanimation
oui la plupart étaient ne sont pas à
s'équiper par exemple quand vous prenez
les masses quand vous prenez les gars
tout tout est importé ou bien les
combinaisons de protection tout est
importé c'est maintenant qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui est tous un peu et
j'essaye d'en fabriquer mais tout est
importé et ouvrir de chine et donc
chaque réglementation qui sera plus
darchy elle s'applique à acétylène je
prends le cas simple des masques la
dernière de tout dernièrement lui la
chine avait pris une décision en disant
que tout dispositif sur lequel il ne
sera pas marquée que c'est un dispositif
médical ne doit pas être utilisé dans un
hôpital
donc du coup il ya des millions de
masques qui était aux commandes et qui
était arrivé qu'il faut jeter parce que
c'est pas écrit dessus
disposent-ils médicale alors que les
mêmes masques étaient utilisés jusque là
sans aucune difficulté
donc ça veut dire que à chaque fois et
son besoin de courir derrière une
nouvelle réglementation ou de courir
derrière des solutions en fonction de ce
que le producteur décide donc ça c'est
qu'il ya énormément de problèmes de
ravitaillement en matière de masques en
matière de qu'en matière de protection
des personnels je vous voyais en afrique
du sud il ya eu beaucoup de mérite
le mexique a été contaminée qu'en ce
moment merci pour toutes ces précisions
ces iem nous rappelle que vous êtes
médecin chirurgien et référent
télémédecine
l'union africaine